the first one even babbling he's gonna
tell us about the cordova grass & Spas
semi-definite thank you so this is work
I started more than 10 years ago with
your Kim Dao who was a postdoc at UCLA
it was now at music and then continued
with Martin Anderson any function as her
PhD students so the results are not
really new but that's all it was a nice
subject for this workshop because it's
as an example of how discrete
optimization and graph theory is or can
be used and continuous optimization so
the talk is about sparse semi-definite
optimization so we look at an SDP in
standard form n is the dimension of the
matrix variable always n by n we have M
equality constraints X is positive
semi-definite we use a trace inner
product for the objective and the
Equality constraints and then we're
interested in applications where the
coefficient C and a I are extremely
sparse that's happens for example of in
relaxations as the p relaxations of
problems that have some underlying
network structure or certain sparsity
patterns that are very common for
example robust disk wares and robust
optimization or matrix no optimization
you have to have sparse t patterns that
have a narrow structure with the
diagonal and a few tens rows and columns
and a problems that just arise from
modeling tools like CVX they're often
very sparse with some irregular sparsity
pattern because of all the new variables
and constraints that are introduced so
it's a problem it in order n-squared
variables because X is an N by n matrix
and typically to make X feasible X has
to be dense to make it positive
semi-definite there's a lot of freedom
in the choice of X because the
coefficients and X the entries of X and
X to the P
it comes in two constraints the Equality
constraints and the objective form a
very sparse set of coefficients and the
other coefficients have to be or not
completely free but it's sufficient that
there exists to make X positive
semi-definite so that's the type of
structure we'd like to exploit in
solving sparse semi definite
optimization problems and we'll look at
the structure in X results from the
sparsity or more accurately the freedom
in choosing most entries of X that
results from the sparsity
using some tools from graph theory and
[Music]
sparse matrix theory so to just give
some notation so we'll use the standard
representation of a sparse the pattern
of a symmetric matrix as a graph so
there are n vertices if there are if
it's an N by n matrix we represented by
an undirected graph with edges E and the
edges represent the off diagonal
non-zeros in the matrix and it's a fact
the absence of an edge that has the
information so for example in this
matrix there's no edge between 3 & 4 and
that means that 3 4 & 3 must be 0 the
other entries the entries on the
diagonal and the off diagonal entries
that are adjacent in the graph may or
may not be 0 the in public cause this
syntactic zeros it's a nice time for the
zeros and the sparsity pattern the other
ones may or may not be 0
so I'll use this notation for the set of
matrices with a certain sparsity pattern
so n is the dimension the symmetric
matrices of order N and sparsity pattern
e because of this if definition also a
matrix can have or the sparsity pattern
of a matrix is not unique if a matrix
has a certain sparsity pattern and i add
an edge in the graph and the matrix also
has that extended sparsity pattern and
we'll call that an extension of sparsity
pattern
for the some points that I talk it's
important to keep in mind that I always
consider the diagonal of the matrix as
non zeros I never force include diagonal
entries as the zeros and the sparsity
pattern and when I refer to click our
mean by click a maximal complete sub
graph in the graph so it's more common
to use the term click for just a
complete sub graph and maximal clique
for a maximal complete sub graph but
here I use click for a maximal complete
sub graph and the clicks in a sparse the
graph correspond to maximal dense
principal sub matrices in the matrix for
example this one 5/3 is a clique in the
graph I corresponds to and three by
three principal sub matrix of non zeros
again in the sense that all these
entries may or may not be 0 that's just
notation and then we can define for a
given sparsity pattern any given
symmetric sparsity pattern to
interesting matrix cones the first one
to matrix cons in the space of symmetric
matrices with that sparsely pattern the
first one are the positive semi definite
matrices by the given sparsity pattern
for example for a band pattern you can
consider the positive semi definite band
matrix with a band matrices with that
pattern so you can write it as an
intersection of the positive semi
definite matrix cone in n by n matrices
and the subspace of matrices with a
sparse dependent so that's a cone of
positive semi definite matrices with a
given pattern and the second cone is the
cone of sparse matrices that have a
positive semi definite completion we can
write it as a projection of the positive
semi definite cone on the subspace of
matrices where that's partially palem
any positive semi definite n by n matrix
projected on the sparsity pattern which
is just orthogonal projection which
means just set all the elements in X
that must be 0 in the sparsity pattern
equal to 0 then you obtain a positive
semi definite complete
matrices and soap ie will always denote
the projection orthogonal projection on
the subspace what matrices better given
spots dependent so these two cones are
obviously convex this is an intersection
of convex cones this is an projection of
a convex cone the clothes that are
pointed they have no.19 terior and those
properties are always also fairly
straightforward except perhaps that the
second one is closed so if you project
the positive semi definite matrix cone
you get a closed cone but that follows
from the assumption of the convention
that the diagonal entries are all
included in a sports mm wouldn't be true
otherwise and they're two dual cones so
these two cones form a pair of primal
and dual cones for the standard trace
inner product so with that notation we
can look at these parts SDP and we write
them in an equivalent notation so if
this is a sparse the standard form is
the P that I started from this is the
dual of the standard form is DP then in
the primal problem if the coefficients
are very sparse I can make the
simplification that replace the conic
inequality that X is positive
semi-definite by replacing or
considering X as a sparse matrix with
our given sparsity pattern with a
constraint that must be positive
semi-definite completable
and the sparsity pattern I use here is
the union of the sparsity patterns of
all the coefficients in the SDP and this
is actually not a new problem or less
just notation but it distinguishes
between the entries of X in the sparsity
pattern and those are the entries that
are multiplied with nonzero coefficients
in C and AI those are the important
entries and the other entries that in
general nonzero but it's sufficient to
know that they exist and make the matrix
positive semi-definite to make these two
problems equivalence
so it's more or less just a change in
notation but it's an important one
because X here is an in general dense
matrix variable the X matrix here is a
sparse matrix variable that are given
sparse the pattern the union of the
sparsity patterns of all the
coefficients and the constraint it's not
that X is positive semi-definite but
that X has an positive semi-definite
completion if you look at the dual
problems then this is the standard dual
of the standard formula P bit and matrix
S that is positive semi definite it's
like matrix and the inequality here it's
more obvious to make this change in
variables because if s is feasible in
the constraints and it's sufficient to
consider or you can restrict s to sparse
matrix with sparsely pattern that's
given by this aggregate unit diamond all
feasible matrices S will have that
sparsity pattern so the corn here is a
cone of positive semi-definite matrices
with that given sparsity pattern these
are obviously equivalents and then also
these are dual connecting linear
programming problems but the different
cones K and K star so you can
equivalently look at the standard form
these SDPs with an N by n matrix
variables as connect linear programming
problems in a much lower dimensional
space of matrices with sparse a given
sparsity pattern but are no longer
symmetric or self-dual SDPs
you use a definite different cone and
the primal and in the dual problem
example if the the pattern is a band
matrix this is just a banded matrix with
a certain sparsity pattern in general
this would be a positive definite semi
definite matrix so you try to exploit
this the property of this these two
cones using some results from graph
theory so I'll first give some
definitions and properties of coral
graphs and then we look at three
properties of coral sparsity patterns
that are very useful and solving this
despair of chronic LPS so coral graph in
define like this so it's undirected
graph with a property that every cycle
of length four or more has a cord so an
edge joining non-consecutive nodes and
the cycle so this is a non coral graph
because we have a cycle of length four
that does have a cold if I add an edge
between a and C or between B and D it
becomes
coral or equivalently if you have a
cycle of length greater than three you
can always shorten it to a cycle of
length a triangle by taking a shortcut
between chords in there and coral graphs
are known and the different names are
also known as triangular triangulated
in machine learning they known as
decomposable rigid circuit graphs and so
on it's a topic that has been studied
and discovered and rediscovered in many
different fields but first in
combinatorial optimization in the early
1960s and it's an important class of the
perfect graphs and it's actual one of
the first topics that was mentioned and
this program in the lectures by Michelle
Goodman's and perfect graphs or graphs
for which list of problems that are in
generally very difficult like covering
coloring or integrating cliques or
finding the largest clique or in fact
easy and in the case of Koro graphs that
actually extremely easy because they can
be solved by simple greedy methods
in linear algebra and that is sort of
the property or the application area of
that will be useful in this talk there
arise in the study of sparse Leske
factorization and then later in the 80s
and 90s in the study of completion
problems for symmetric matrices a
machine learning there used known as
decomposable graphs and Rison graphical
models and also in continuous
optimization or non-linear optimization
they arise in the study of partial cept
ability so for this talk the most
important areas will be linear algebra
this the second one and then partial
separable T and then semi definite
programming they were first used in this
paper from 97 and several other papers
by Kojima's group since so for our
purposes its seconds application that's
more useful than the definition in terms
of cores of cycles and this is a result
from the very early result by rows who
made a connection with cholesky
factorization so if you take a positive
definite matrix with a given sparse d
pattern e and we use this notation for
the shlonsky factorization so a
permutation matrix P lower unit lower
triangular matrix L positive diagonal D
then rows show that if E is coral then
there exists a permutation matrix for
which you have zero fill so the sparse
the pattern of L is really the same as a
sparse de pattern of a of course la
strangler so it's parsed the pattern of
L plus L transpose that we compare with
a and you have to apply the inverse
permutation if you compare it with the
supports the pattern of a subject to the
reordering it has the same sparsity
pattern as a so a has a zero fill of
cholesky factorization and that's
actually very practical the definition
of a coral sparsity pattern the patterns
for which you have zero fill shlonsky
factorizations and it's actually
necessary and sufficient if you look at
it as a property of the entire set of
sparse matrices
in a sense that if a sparsely pattern is
not coral then you can always find every
permutation matrix you can find matrices
with that pattern for which you have no
zero fill so let's give accusation so
that's a very practical definition of
coral sparsity patterns so it gives us
an idea of how common they are so there
are some simple patterns that we know
about coral the simplest non-trivial one
is a pattern with two overlapping
diagonal blocks and that's that
obviously has a zero fill Scholesy
factorization for just the standard
natural ordering and that's also very
useful pattern when studying properties
or algorithms for coral sparsity
patterns because it's often useful to
first try to prove a result or drive an
algorithm for this special simple case
because if it's true for this special
case it's usually true that you can
extend it to general coral palettes
using the three structures that I'll
discuss band patterns are obviously
coral and then a narrow pattern or a
block arrow Pilon are also coral because
you have a zero fill show less key
factorization an and more generally they
arise in an cholesky factorization of a
general matrix so if in this matrix the
filled circles or the non zeros in
positive definite matrix it's not coral
if you apply Leske factorization after a
reordering you get a fill-in in these
positions and by definition the filled
pattern so the at its edges plus the
original edges form a coral sparsity
pattern and
[Music]
and it's actually a coral extension of
the original sparsity pattern and the
fact that for many spots the patterns
that arise in practice you have fairly
efficient coral extensions or your
things that give you a small fill in
energy to Alaska factorization so
indicates that that's actually quite
useful otherwise partial Eskie
factorization methods wouldn't be as
useful as they are and then skipping a
lot of details an important property of
coral sparsity patterns is that he can
drive several click three structures or
in general elimination three structures
that represent them so this shows a
crick tree or in linear algebra verbs
known as a super noble elimination three
for this coral sparsity pattern so every
block in the tree represents a clique in
the graph every click is partitioned in
two sets so the top row is the
intersection with the parents and the
click the bottom row is the remainder
after the intersection with the parent
and for a coral sparsity pattern you can
construct trees like this with very
special properties one property is that
these bottom rows
form a partition of all the vertices in
the graph so one through seventeen
actually these first rows form a
partition of the set 1 to 17 and that's
already a simple proof that coral graph
cannot have more than n freaks
and a second property is that the clicks
and the click tree that contain a
certain vertex for example vertex 10
former sub tree in the creek 3 so that's
the induced sub 3 property so if you
look for all the clicks that contain 10
and they form this tree and that's the
basis of many recursive algorithms
formulated as recursions on these trees
in topological or inverse topological
order the fact that the cliques that
contain a certain vertex form a sub tree
and degree 3 so in linear algebra these
first rows will be called the super
nodes or maximal super nodes in and
there are many equivalent or relaxed
definitions if you renumber these super
nodes you can rearrange them every all
neatly in an matrix like this where
every super node has just defines the
brock column of columns that have the
same structure the same zero nonzero
structure and it's also useful to know
that it exists very efficient methods
for computing these click trees or in
fact given a non choral graph and an
ordering for constructing all the
important statistics about this clique
tree without actually constructing it
and construct the super nodes and a
clique tree the child parent structure
in the clique 3 computer filling that
you have after the extension all in
almost linear time in the size of the
original graph not the phil gramm and
before actually computing the filled
graph
so these are just the we'll need for to
know about coral grafts and I know if
you look back go back to the sparse is
the P problem you look at three
applications of coral graph theory too
sparse semi-definite programming the
first one relates to very classical
properties of these two sparse matrix
cones that I defined in the beginning
and ever
derived in the 80s so the first one is
this suppose we consider the cone of
positive semi-definite matrices with a
given coral sparsity pattern and you
have this nice decomposition resulted if
a matrix has a certain let's call
sparsity pattern and it's positive semi
definite if and only if you can write it
as a sum of simple positive semi
definite matrices so this is a very
simple coral sparsity pattern with three
kliks matrix with this structure is
positive semi definite if and only if
you can write it as a sum of three
positive semi definite matrices that
have this very simple structure one for
each click in the sports department
and the general formula gets a little
complicated because we the HR matrices
here are these dense sub matrices and
then we have to copy them to the right
position in the N by n matrix so this is
obviously compositional decomposition
ideas though obviously sufficient to
make the some positive semi-definite but
for Coral matrices it's also necessary
and this actually appeared I think first
in a paper by agree on can't Wong who
were considered or studying sparse
quasi-newton updates so they were
interested in the question if this is
for example the Hessian of a quadratic
function a pole or a convex quadratic
function and this property means that he
can write a quadratic function as a sum
of simple quadratic functions that each
involve only a few variables that's a
partial partial separable ax T structure
in the matrix
and this is actually also easy to see if
we follows from this property of the
zero Phyllis key factorization so if you
just look at the proof for a simple case
of two overlapping blocks so you want to
show that every positive semi-definite
matrix with this structure can be
written as a sum of these two well we
can take the zero fill a Schillaci
factorization of this which is a lower
triangular matrix with the same
structure and then collect the outer
products and this product and take the
first block column times its transpose
and it gives us a matrix of this form
and then the second block column times
its transpose and again the matrix of
this form it's actually just another way
of saying that the matrix has a positive
semi definite zero fish let's give
factorization and these matrices also it
turns out are computed as a byproduct of
a multi frontal Schillaci factorization
known as the update matrices in a multi
frontal USQ factorization so computing a
decomposition like this is also very
cheap an optimization is very useful
because it means that we write this
complicated cone of positive semi
definite matrices with a given pattern
as a sum of very simple cones for the
second Matrix cone is there was a cone
of positive semi-definite computable
matrices we have the dual result and a
dual result is that a matrix with the
structure is positive semi definite is
positive semi definite computable if
every click defines positive semi
definite some matrix
and that follows from the first result
and duality because if this is the dual
cone of a cone that you can write as a
sum of simple cones then the dual cone
is the intersection of the two cones in
this case the intersection of the duals
of the simple cones are just defined by
these inequalities so this historically
actually came first its results but you
can mention also derive it from the
first result and then into ality so
these results are very useful in
algorithms for solving a sparse SDP
because it means that in a sparse SDP we
can always that was the sparse SDP and a
non-symmetric connect form as I
discussed you can always assume that the
sparsity pattern the union of this parts
de patterns is coral by considering a
coral extension and then it means that
we can take this complicated constraint
X in this positive semi-definite
compatible cone and look at this
constraint as a union as an intersection
of very simple constraints can replace
this constraint by just saying that
every completely specified dance
principle sub matrix must be positive
semi-definite and that's the setting in
which many different decomp first-order
and splitting methods apply every time
you have an complicated constraint set
that can be written as an intersection
of simple sets in a sense that you can
easily come project on a set you can
apply a whole range of different methods
exactly dmm do block coordinate descent
methods
and so the details are very different in
different applications but depending on
the equality constraints you can
actually apply many types of
decomposition and spitting methods and
these ideas actual first use not in
first order methods but in interior
point methods and the conversion methods
that were presented in these papers so
that's the first application of choral
graph theory on these parts and semi
definite programming problems the second
one is then interior point methods using
these properties to speed up interior
point methods so again we can look at
the problem as the original SDP with a
self-dual a pair of dual Sal dual
symmetric constraints and primal and
dual or as a non symmetric pair of
connect LPS with a different cone in
primal and dual positive semi-definite
compatible cone or positive
semi-definite cone with a given pattern
in the dual advantages that we look at
optimization problems in possibly much
lower dimensional space then in this
problem especially X here is a sparse
matrix here it's the dense matrix in
general the downside is we cannot use
symmetric primal dual interior point
methods because the cones are not tools
but if we can efficiently formulate
barrier functions for these two cones we
can formulate primal or dual baffling
ordering methods that actually solve
these conical pit problems primal
question is do we have efficient
barriers for these two cones so to
answer that we can first look at simpler
one it's the positive semi-definite
matrices with given sparsity pattern the
second cone so there it's obvious what
the barrier would be you just take the
standard lock that better but you
restricted to matrices with a given
sparsity pattern so that's the minus log
that s the gradient of the log that
barrier is just a negative of the
universe but if you look at it as a
function from the space of may
with the given sparsity pattern and the
gradient becomes the projection on the
sparsity pattern of the negative
universe so here and that's true in
general for any sparsity pattern that a
question is can we easily compute this
projection to compute the projection you
have to find the entries and the inverse
which in general is a dense matrix but
you're only interested in the entries
that are in the sparsity by them if it's
a band pattern it's the main band of the
inverse the expression is true in
general but the question is can be
computed efficiently and for the hessian
it gets a little more complicated but if
you apply the hessian to a sparse matrix
in the same space that means you
linearize the gradients in that
direction and you get this expression
for the hessian without a projection
again it's the hessian of the log that
barrier applied to matrix y in this
lower dimensional space you have to
project this expression to get the
Hessian that is applied to an Direction
Y and again the question is can be
easily compute this expression that
actually computing these inverses or
computing this entire product which
would be dance and so the answer is
that's true for again coral sparse de
patterns you have very efficient
formulas for the barrier gradient and
Haitian again follows from the zero fill
property of the show Leske factorization
because if you're asked to compute this
barrier function in general a very good
way to do it is to take an sparsh
alaskey factorization of s and then add
the logs of the diagonal entries and
this rescue factorization
so for example if using a multi frontal
Scholesy factorization to compute L and
D then this algorithm will multi frontal
method will use an recursion elimination
tree in topological order starting at
the leaves of the elimination tree and
then moving towards the root of the tree
so I guess there's a very efficient
method for computing the log that
barrier for the gradient you can
actually give an L and D write an
equation like this by just rearranging
the definition of the Shoeless key
factorization and you get an equation
that the inverse of s satisfies and then
it turns out for the choral sparsely
pattern you can look at this equation
and so for exactly the entries in the
universe that you're interested in
exactly the ones in the pattern and you
don't need to compute any entry and s
inverse that you're not interested in so
this we looked at this and there's no
real report that we found by Tim Davis
and students who also formulated what
the frontal like methods for computing
the gradient and in hindsight that's
maybe not surprising because if you have
an efficient method for computing the
barrier via - rescue factorization and
by automatic differentiation should get
an efficient method for computing the
gradient and it makes sense that this is
an recursion on the elimination tree in
topological order bottom up to the root
then this will be an recursion in
topological order inverse topological
starting at root to the leaves
and then for the machine you get
something similar if you take the
algorithm for computing the gradient
that consistent first computing the
cholesky factorization and doing this
recursion for the gradients and you
linearize all the steps and the
algorithm you get something very
efficient for computing this Hessian
applied to an symmetric sparse matrix
and that algorithm for computing the HT
will involve two recursions for every Y
you'll have an because you linearizing
this distance so that's where a core of
sparsity helps you have very efficient
methods for computing the barrier the
gradient and action so to test this we
looked at some patterns from the
University of Florida collection these
are some statistics on the sparsity
patterns so the dimension number of very
small to about hundred thousand number
of non-zeros and here we compare the
cost of our own imperfect cholesky
factorization for a matrix with that
pattern with the cost of computing as
projected inverse this so the projected
inverse of intense matrix on the
sparsity pattern and the point is that
sony for the larger instances it's
almost exactly the same so you can
compute as projected inverse or the
gradient of the barrier in roughly the
same cost as a Schillaci factorization
of the same it is the same sparsity
pattern
so this is for the positive
semi-definite cone yes II if you write
out the cholesky factorization of course
I skipped all the details of a
multi-front of Scholesy factorization
but there's a very simple recursion
where you go through the click tree or
the elimination tree or the super node
elimination three starting at the leaves
and every step you do some simple
calculations to compute the entire
choice key factorization so it's a
nonlinear each calculation is a
nonlinear simple formula so if you
linearize all these steps you get an
algorithm for the gradient by applying
the chain rule if you put these two
together you first computer show Leske
factorization which maps s to L and D
then the gradient which maps L and D to
this inverse if you linearize all these
steps to compute the this expression so
the hessian applied to Y which is the
derivative of this in an erection while
adjust the chain rule we get an
algorithm for computing this that's an
interpretation of the algorithm once
it's derived its race
so the second duel of this cone is the
positive semi-definite computable corn
there it's more complicated so we use
the log that barrier for the positive
semi-definite corn from convex
optimization to suggest the barrier for
the positive semi-definite completable
corn is the dual or the conjugate
barrier so I would mean to evaluate it
at a given matrix X with a positive
definite completion you solve this
optimization problem in s this is a
sparse matrix sparse positive semi
definite matrix and then the value of
this optimization problem of value gives
you the value of the barrier so this
optimization problem is actually also
very interesting because it turns out
that the optimal s in this problem is
the inverse of the maximum determined
completion for the matrix X at which you
evaluate the barrier so this problem
that arises in the definition of the
conjugate barrier is equivalent to this
optimization problem where you fix X
you're looking for a matrix Z that
completes X with maximum determines that
the Z the maximum determined completion
is a dense matrix its inverse will be
this optimal s and that's a sparse
matrix
and I want from this maximum determined
completion or its inverse you get the
gradient and the Hessian by just
standard results for the Chandra
transforms so again these are true in
general
for a general pattern you would have to
solve this minimization problem or the
maximum deterrent completion problem
numerically for a Korell pattern you
actually have very simple again multi
frontal style algorithms for computing
this matrix s and therefore also the
gradient and Hessian by a recursion over
the clique tree again it's a similar
spot where we now compare the cholesky
factorization for a given pattern with
the cost of computing the gradients of
this dual barrier and it's a little more
expensive because there is some small
linear equation you have to solve with
roughly speaking at the end of the same
order so the conclusion is you can
formulate for a coral sparsity path and
find the define locate the barrier
functions for the primal and the dual
cone and compute all the barrier and the
gradient hashing very efficiently so
then you can formulate primal dual
barrier methods the advantages that you
save load and the cost of computing the
chute complement system which is one of
the main terms and the complexity of a
general positive semi-definite interior
point method for example if you have a
band matrix a band pattern and the
number of constraints is fixed and is
very n for a given bandwidth you get a
cost per iteration that's linear in the
cost of computing the gradient and the
Hessian and so on is linear for an
primal dual symmetric method it would be
worse than the year would be you expect
something else cubic
and a given bandwidth and the same is
true for arrow patterns since has been
used in several papers so the closest
tool that described is a paper by
pyrolysis and then we had a paper in
2010 here's some results that we
constructed some test problems where the
cost of computing the shoe compliment
system in any zero-point minute was
really the dominant term and the
complexity so we have very large
matrices from size 2002 30,000 with a
small number of constraints and it's
really the cost of computing the shoe
complement system that dominates and
then you can solve this is a cost per
iteration and it's an old table from
2010 all the numbers will be much lower
today I think the general trend would be
similar except maybe for SD PSC because
I think has been an important upgrade
since then
that's using log-in non-symmetric
interior point methods yes these will
still be in
so last is a small comment on the
minimum rent completion so we discussed
positive semi-definite completion in
general we had this important
characterization of the matrix with a
Korell sparse the pattern is completed
with a positive semi-definite completion
of each of the clicks defines a positive
semi-definite matrix we looked at the
maximum determined completion but you
can also look at a minimum rank a
positive semi-definite completion which
for a general pattern would be a very
difficult problem but for a Korell
pattern it turns out that that's also
quite easy and there is a result from
dances from 92 that says that minimum
rank the rank of the minimum rank posts
the semi left completion is the largest
of these ranks largest rank of all the
completely specified sub matrices so
that's obviously an lower bounds on the
minimum rank of a rank of a minimum rank
completion that is actually equal in a
case of a choral matrix and that's easy
to see also if you go back to the simple
to block overlapping choral pattern so
the question will be this you have an
matrix with this pattern not to find
replace the zero with something that
keeps the entire made or that makes them
it entire matrix positive semi definite
and of minimum rank so the condition for
this to be possible is that these two
sub matrices are positive semi definite
and then the rank the maximum of these
two ranks gives us the rank of the
minimum rank completion and that's can
be seen as follows so we take the
specified these two blocks you can
factorize them with any factorization
but the number of columns we assume and
these factorizations is the minimum of
the two ranks can always add zeros to
make it equal so you know these two or
can compute these two factorizations and
then if you look at a block where they
in the middle they overlap then you have
these two matrices V and V Taylor that
give you there's equality V V transpose
V tilde V T so the transpose so that
means that they're related by an
orthogonal matrix can find an orthogonal
matrix that
Maps X V equal to V to the times Q and
then from that matrix can construct an
completion of the matrix that has the
same dimension as the maximum of these
two just compute these two blocks you
compute a new block and if you work out
this product you see it agrees with the
original matrix in the specified
positions but it's obviously also has
this same rank so that's the
construction for two blocks and then you
can apply that to in general Coral
pattern by iterating this over a clique
three you will start at root of the
clique three that's your second block in
this simple example and then you keep
adding constructing a matrix like this
YY transpose that gives you a completion
and you add one block and Y for each
supernova at a time you never have to
revise the work that you already done so
you complete a complete completion with
rank equal to the maximum of these ranks
so it's also very useful should be
useful in algorithms because it means in
an sparse SDP that you can also enjoy
this problem may be strictly feasible so
general X will be a full rank but you
can always replace X by low rank outer
product with rank bounded by the largest
clique in the aggregate pattern of CNA
is useful for many purposes can be used
to round the exact of the result of an
interior point method if you apply two
in relaxation and also to prove simple
simple proofs of simple relaxation
exactness
okay so should stop here so we looked at
actually some applications of coral
graphs and coral sparsity coral sparse
matrices in sparse semi-definite
optimization so many in decomposition
methods and the implementation of not
symmetric well you can have a bridge
from this because if you have an
arbitrary sparse situation then their
problem of adding the minimum number of
edges could graph to make it 404 though
is empowered I don't I forgot what the
approximation status of this problem is
but this is definitely a very very
useful you know people use minimum
degree or some very simple heuristics
but if you can reduce the number of
edges that has to be added to make the
graph for though that's equivalent to
making the least amount of filling in so
that's that's a very nice problem for
approximation
thank the speaker again
[Applause]